hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar towards HCV elimination a case
study of taiwan i am michelle ashton of
laberd's and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots and
brought to you by Abbott molecular to
learn more about our sponsor please
visit www.dent.umich.edu/license
click on the support tab found at the
top-right of the presentation window or
report your problems by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational unless offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit I now present today's
speaker dr. Ming Leung you distinguished
professor at Gao Xiang medical
University in gaussians Taiwan's
an adjunct professor at the college of
biological science and technology and
met the National Xiao Tong University
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen professor you you may
now begin your presentation
today the intern gentlemen I'm in on you
run caution medical university they I
would like to share the experience of
the case study in Taiwan to water
advisory board elimination
probably he has estimate about 71
million people are currently living with
receive honest
and more than half of the people in the
asia-pacific and about the 10% over 71
million people living with the virus
i resided in the southeast asia however
barely only 1% of the patient population
is aware that they had the disease it
means that this ultimate lack of
awareness in the asia-pacific
the World Health Organization pwh oh the
lungs not giving in advantage patterns
to be achieved by 2030 because we had to
look the surprises as a public health
issue so lobby which owed to the goo in
reducing 90% of new innovations and the
city better send along today from
biological parties by 2030 in Curitiba
Google by 2030 there are three major
strategy we have chillie agreement
including the pre mention the tennis
team and the treatment in terms of a
hundred percent of blood donations
should be screened and the 90 percent of
all of the of the arm the arm killaby ID
should be a set to serve injection to
prevent that happening prior to
impatience and then we had to test 90
percent or more people we say product
IDs to diagnose and occupy B and C and
finally we had to reach 80 percent or
more eligible patients with heavy or Hep
C treated
it is a long way to achieve the goal by
2030
therefore the wh show that another MIT
can go by 2020 achieved thirty to fifty
percent our city population imbalanced
fifty to seventy percent of the eligible
patients peaking treatment and the
ninety percent of all on location should
be treated and cured ever to achieve
that we can go by 2020 in asia-pacific
baby countries should set a strategy or
so-called ninja nation print initiated
the ninja nation print by a nation of
Alaska party surveillance program and
also in combination with strategy to
stop the leak our limitations in terms
of suggesting policy in credit care
settings and the family budgeting
program to assess up t up to seventy
percent or more or the person who inject
drugs in each country's
choose which big gg-go battalion surgeon
you have a tube know about what is the
gap and the how to bridge lookit this is
an estimation by as a 2013 by whao
as you can see other times they are huge
get in the children rate just only along
the April so another case you had been
treated and also another huge gap in the
Dinos bridge that's only 20% of the
patient bed in Bangor purple to actually
go you have to overcome and took reader
get in this community so the first step
is that we have to know what is the
barrier for the satellites curtain in
this password you can see there many
memories for van appetites testing
including the likes of public and
knowledge meant and the like our
awareness among the healthcare providers
local easy to access 50 and people fear
of the mother and discrimination and
also the impact out out-of-pocket cost
so to bridge the gap the not derecho
recommend we have to race with our
disease awareness not only in public
also in the case care provider and that
to making the to make it a tender more
accessible and last and finally to
remove the cost barriers for balaclava
testing as well as for the children cost
2019 Walker Pied de camión the whu-oh
advocate find the mission minutes to
raise the thesis awareness in on the
topic also the face care provider and
then we have to scare other HCV program
and initially is make the diagnosis more
accessible there are children to the
emotional capacity was impatience
the first one is patient-centered these
satellite systems in the next we can
place the simple or locally without the
sender sent go to the central laboratory
using the point-of-care platform such as
the Russia such as the dry blood spot
collecting we just call it the deliver
or collided with the dry blood hot spots
we can diagnose the occasion we saw with
an anti ACB of the body and even we go
without a CBR a another it provides the
accurate and affordable Dinah's tool and
also in to integrate into the
centralized I think with I see on the
party tennis team and they she be
increasing testing and this strategy we
cannot call it a block up in in large
amounts understand abroad that to the
level central level testing and tangible
anti-syrian body air into the HTV on the
bodies partly and then tested she really
with or without a CV genotype
and the finally operational key note
strategy to improve the gap is to remove
the cost barrier
now either ballot testing also the
shitty syrup
to reduce the cost of a logistic we can
integrate the up surveillance program
into the other so-called multi-purpose a
surveillance program such as HIV the
blood sugar with the brandy pit and as
we are to be other our public health
surveillance so that we can ascend
costly and for the affordable SCV
therapy is a very useful teaching the
major power such as an engine
reimbursements and negotiate with
industry and we can reduce the cost of
achieving syrupy and even cover all the
cost by the nation budgets therefore we
can provide the free all very very
affordable to therapy for the HIV
patients
so the European Association is Polisario
Bieber recommends a simplification under
a Shiva diagnosis and treatment in 2018
this speaker are in luxury to be
simplification of the ICB skimming the
treatment and assessments
so far we just are screen the patient
with untidy Baldy and you put a patient
pulse with us but achievin are an ID on
the body we can confirm the patients
with or without the ID invasion by using
the HTV nuclear on a seat
you could see the testing with or
without this mobile or testing because
currently most of the treatment
algorithm did not use the best mobile or
as Scheidemann
deviation as a treatment to racing
strategy so if the patient were part are
positive or as she be on a we can
initiate the treatment whistle very
simple toes simple dosing sure that your
integration richmond so called a
diverging violates george member da
which man with the pen genotypic a daa
such as a so far plus a detox korea so
fast for personal benefit a severe organ
operator concept invented beer with all
we know to Broadway in a two cherries
and just assess the trigger a week Rd
trip a twenty rupees after another ta a
server key so it's a very simple
strategy spooning confirmation treats
and assessment table using the
simplification strategy we are able to
achieve the SUV elimination by 2030
by my country we can implement the the
CV elimination program it because the
revolutional are advanced in the
undeveloped regimen in the tested 30
years after we all met without the
undeveloped syrupy notice only 15 to 25
percent location cook spontaneous
recover from the HIV at UCB in pastries
and that is used about using the by
using the effort approved that
ambivalent agents the interpol on in
early 90 we can just only kill 9 percent
to 30 percent of our patients with
interferon okay getting people on
therapy and we terminate car people in
poverty 50 to 80 percent by using the
particular lady in the prompt as robbery
in 24 to 48 ways and currently the new
press through the relative antiviral
agents but only a to Terry's arm which
the newly introduced PA therapy you can
cure up to 95 percent on patient with a
very high so people
that the let's fight you are currently
can implement the so-called recordable
Achebe a diminishing program so today
I'd like to show you the nationwide
investigation of real world community
Fatima names in a seviche dominant the
project of the mic elimination for paws
making travel the HTV imaging by 2025 in
Taiwan and this program is funded by the
time only Research Foundation is a
non-profit and non-government
organizations in collaborate in
collaboration with culture medical
university and the cultural medical
university of the 80s healthcare system
background is at achieving patient the
emerging put on the intercom baster key
to interpreting three that were
ambivalent television 26:14 enters the
positive goal or achieving in managing
by 2030 certified by the public oh we
can do Lisa R nationwide investigations
propose making to eating an aid to the
balance in Taiwan and as she has in the
area
pebble we have a tooth respected to
complete the issue
the first one is to know but we are but
we are extremely concerned and then to
realize the cost it was to cure a
patient n1 and finally to set the
strategy on how you can be done to
eliminate about us in Taiwan
first step is to know where we are in
the CV control I have to know where we
are in issue control
we control the model to evaluate the
rate of disease diagnosis awareness
ability children rate and chronicle
articles they are silly as a nation wave
as you can see the lifestyle table the
Mable Taiwan's
the edges adjust and actually translate
one around the 3.3% image along the
sudden my honza sullen as a 350,000
people had been infected with the grass
and the currents along the hub and
meaning people are going further in
fighting each other bars it because
there are many hyper actually in any
area in East Alden with cars over Taiwan
in some countries it's the
silicon's really as high as 30 percent
but but looking at the the trillion
great success for children rates of our
technology in film photography you can
see these are 24 weeks or the plague by
bar you can cure 89% of genotype to
patients and the 30% ultimate of our
patients and because of the genotype
dissipation intervals around half of
recent one and two chill apart so we
asked made the overall as well rate was
around the nineteen eighty percent for
the education in kind line in the past
twenty years
look at the weak community settings we
find that we just only kill around even
to send all our patients this model is
constructed by the NGO and our hospital
we found leads there are only 49% of the
patient care Celia women's and only 19%
occasion have been assessed of their she
Matisse's is a clinic and only 13% of
the patient had been treated with
speculating in the program and only 11
percent allocation kdq even the kinetic
art but as high as 80% and a 5 so many
patient had not been treated a typical
that a lot of vision was ineligible she
looked happy different robbery and the
ones of the patient they are other
muscle bands and another one in say so
patient had no insurance cover and the
one and the tango sanitation had no
therapy awareness
- Nicole our CV region by 2030 we have
to increase the rates of pixies
diagnosis awareness or suitability and
introduce new antiviral with high Q base
and septic program we are lucky that in
2016 we have Oh almost all available via
enrichment so here I like to introduce
you briefly all of the license erosion
image Scheidemann of heaven I see
currently the first one is 20 what we's
arsenic river and protease inhibitor
first ilaria and inspire a inhibitor in
a tremendous opportunity one leakages in
that global and depending spacer is
trying can see the 24 is regiment
páginas Anwar be could kill this patient
population with an SVR rate a lot of 85
this thing I've been looking at it for
the patient with or without baseline
reduce Association confusion at the end
inspired religions you can see equal
page in carry and inspire was a bellow
31 or 193 the 24 we saw a similar plots
are done last via just only kill around
the 40% notation by with a patient has a
mole boss the SVR raided crew will
achieve as high of 90 purposes
therefore to treat a patient of
Unabomber 1b with this regimen we have
to test and as far as people we
prescribe average to avoid attributed
failure
second version is repairable and protein
protease inhibitor would still the
perpetual number in combination with
unbeatable and then inspire inhibitor
with or without Donna Tartt's traveler
is a nest by Iran nuke which also rubber
in Portugal Taiwan and both actually
contain the left-side toolbar carries
all the protein rich man with rubber
ring to kill around the 95 percent of
the patients with all university roses I
will look at the most aquatic killer
populations the genotype 1 a primal
responder to prior interpreting and have
best my pasta doses cable switchmen just
only can curate extent compared to 93%
of the SPLA if we in extending the three
children were able to reach into 24
weeks
but for the AIDA computer population
ecology multi-run be the protein
richmond without the barbering to kill
over the genome that one be patient with
altered by burying recently three away
in the nineteen nineties and the
furthermore the genotype and phenotype
or patient's the 2d judgment poppy dog
put stated target or number in
combination with unbeatable password are
being rerouted us a fever caused a cure
on a hundred percent o2 network for
patients Tyler
the first to Richmond the Dallas blood
for the regimen and asuna played a lot
with credible with wouldn't allow me
accordingly
not the first choice because out written
low Chillicothe and high here burden and
high-touch total interaction between the
DDI and the co mobility yeah for our
currently this to Richmond are rarely
been prescribed in the real world
and the third Regiment is on
combinational second combination of
protease inhibitor comes an inspiring
Hitler with the operator a bass via the
CH pastry program demonstrates the
Trailways regimen could cure around the
95 percent of Latino night one vocations
however to deny Evo is peering while the
Savanti Romero I deliver the pastries
are genotype one a we space might
inspire Ross the trend every currency
with travel judgment a zombie around the
50 percent therefore for this patient
population we have three standard
regimen from three ways to sitting with
and aid in the robbery to ensure
accessibility and also volatility spills
patients of genotype flow in the page in
apparent more responder color balance
failure we also have to edit the rubbery
to ensure that really crunchy if you
choose will repeal and may possibly ask
the DA a watchman
and the force the arrangement is the
most need mostly new the arrangement is
second generation of protease inhibitor
correct comfortable and the second
dimensional an aspiring to be the
current a three pistols combinations
recovery day is only a waste of Richmond
we can cure around the 99% of Oh ology
no time without cirrhosis it's very
powerful regiment and liver the paging
have a compensated cirrhosis but it is
too annoying again only head with on a
grid peak can cure over the genotype of
this patient population which as we
already ate a 98 percent even the very
thick cut clear population the genotype
3 generally we see what occasions weaken
to a 95% of the patient with just on the
egg-wich regimen but other children his
parents aging with compensated OSes
carries regimen could also cure along
the 99% therefore between disappearance
compensating services we have to apply a
travel regime of GP to ensure
illegitimate occurs and the photo driven
experience fiber lungs erotic or
cirrhotic patients with renal try stream
the optimal regime only seeking ways of
GP listen Estrella rate analysis person
and so the bases are the erosion is so
called off so fast web based therapy is
an expired Nick
the nucleotides analog the nuclear
Arnold a therapy tapas were cousin the
deepest fear and inspire inhibitor or
chair with King pure chip of the
genotype one patience is a very highest
be arrayed along the body vitamins are
the tree knowledge or experience either
for the lady deep particular population
for the leader of this periodic cannot I
want patients the optimal treatment
regimen is trail we so as well plus not
maybe pass fear or I ate in the robbery
and then 10 the trail with Richmond
therefore you can ensure that unit
cousin and the mighty is percent or more
but but we need to kill population the
genotype one is low bass knob Ariel but
the most cysts meaning are you commune
just only a ways also lady could kill
more than ninety by personal patient
population and later arm this regimen is
also approved the treatment of genotype
2 which were approved in Taiwan and
Japan and also watching the type for
violence's discredit a pro in all over
under the war
and the loss of judgment is casa da
which may he saw possible plus our way
possible pistols combination one popular
deport railways this is a supporter base
therapy process second generation or and
inspire in Thibodaux and the Ostrava
three program as well one two three
demonstrator very high-end genetic
currency hotel with judgments this SPR
trail rates of ninety nine percent in
general population and currently is a
wire used the enrichment or the latino
track and even for the very special
populations the so will also can cure
the patient with very Heights as we are
clear rate for example asked for
treating the patient with capacity
compensations for all the genotype as we
are equal achieve ninety four percent by
aiding the robbery to the software and
therefore the soleus robbery or chair
wings of so lady parts laboratories oh
so far so attract a lot military's first
level we are currently indicator in the
children of say pathetic immunization
but for all the judgment with protease
inhibitor it is contraindicated in the
treatment of the patient with a pathetic
concentration and also this version in
hydrometallurgy on HIV as she called
beijing in extra fine 95s name and
possibly the transplantations asians
research generated 96% and the children
or adolescents with a despair weight of
92 in the 95% and more recently just
destroyed when just approved in a
treatment a patient with end-stage renal
disease and the are hemodialysis with
our discussant a profile and high safety
and the hajiman rate cuts at 95%
so maybe sentiment kureta we have the
many in there parody arrangements this
way - hi - Annette can see simple
building and very show - delivered to
the ventilation only eight to tear ways
and high 70 profile we just can see a
light at the end of tunnel that is a
hawk to kill AV achieve in Beijing
however there are some up impact of the
current available be a which the first
one is the huge about Ebert it because
at the time of the new year its
introduction the cost
every time to kill a patient you had to
pay around the 11 solid 287 US dollars
and the second impact is the warehouse
patient or the wheel fiber impact on
probation manpower because a lot
occasion wait for the new R P enrichment
and we have come to the canonical at the
same time and in terms of the profession
in power available with to overcome the
barrier we have a to evaluate to the
cost-effectiveness of the way Rd battle
and also put to priority by the our
patient to receive at the edge
so therefore the second steps of our
problem is to determine of course it
cost it is worse to cure a patient in
Taiwan therefore you increment this our
study to evaluate the cost effectiveness
of the test cut in different us
preparing for city by linking a real
work for go to the nation s insurance
database as a reference of the a cost
for puzzle makers near to sovereign she
be patient Reuters picking different US
robbery were evaluate and he found bikes
to kill to successfully to kill
successively cure a seviche note on one
page in here to appear around the $8,300
in my patient and babbling in the
experimentation and to kill the genotype
to patients we have to pay along there
4600 you standard support 90 patients
and and also around the table of the
course in a experienced haematite
rotations so after adjustment the price
and the genotype dispersion we we
estimate we are optimal treatment cost
also super trivalent which are played by
bar in the past is along a solid and 50
US dollars therefore the nature of s
ensures at administration or China on
approve to reimburse pistols
our fifth cause of uses US dollars a
thousand and three hundred successful
for successful criminals with any D here
which will party patients with any
condition in 2016 so by now we can
overcome the budget the budget impact
because you can custom the clear
regiments for SBH because as we achieve
the from more under our unum around the
10 to 80 at insulin to a d7 to only a
three US dollars tada
moving with a scale of total budget is
very terrible budget impact because
around the heart meaning orientations in
Taiwan and the Tabata we're a lot of
four billion US dollars therefore either
to divide a strategy or privatization of
the a therapy in Taiwan so the suspect
in this project is to realize how it can
be done to invent and SCB and it is a
duster allocation catalystic
hello cell carcinoma in the most risky
complication algae so the most optimal
goal or the Seabee treatment is to
reduce or to prevent the de belem health
retinal cell carcinoma and but what
Harbor the practice we associate with
decision of the system biology response
based on the product our study the
refined reticular whispered the first
one is settles unchangeable or fractured
such as gender diabetes healthy label LT
male organ achieving and the second good
risk is the presence wheel wasn't its
time because it's time degenerative
lattice is H and commodified [ __ ]
elbow we conducted study around the 1200
patients that were treated by a provider
and linked to the nation in service tree
and compared the risk of another cell
carcinoma presentation with and without
successful voila modifications as you
can see this is a destiny figure is
there are no difference between the
patient with or without successful and
the velocity in the page in the risk of
hepatocellular carcinoma will the
patient just only have three more five
or six petals it's called little and one
but for the patient with significant or
other balanced events watch if my boss
sees a chip and O's SVR could be used as
user hepatocellular carcinoma remarkably
and by looking at the FF our age similar
stretching but also about the location
of less than forty years old
achieving SPL not to know impaired and
as a possible customer risk about the
patient with age morning forty years of
shaming them as we are should reduce the
risk alphabetical cost about a cell
carcinoma remarkably there for our study
demonstrates we have a treat the patient
with advanced fibrosis or each patient
as early as possible to avoid the
development of hepatocellular carcinoma
therefore the major health insurance ok
one approach early birth the arrangement
for creation's with privacy state stream
book into science esteem in so-called
the validation of PS erotic based on the
hypothesis letters
systems on 17 the government of Taiwan
start to reimburse the DA the first year
budget is 75 million u.s. dollars and
three steerage words are were approval
to part with a population of - on
patients only patients research we are
late and had a hypothesis calls real for
compete with brusque and the universe
paper just only chibin experience
patients and later on also to deny
patient could be reversed in the second
years the 2018 the budget increased from
75 million to 114 million and the two
more the evidence was the world we burst
including a sub ribosome lady and
achieving for all of genotype with
country population of 70 sonia pangäa
patients with Justin Bieber's criterion
Francisco's real pole general experience
and she be very and in this year 2019
the DA budget further increased to 220
million u.s. dollars with a targeted
population assist certified solid
patients and broaden the reimbursement
criteria just only with the criteria
just on the anti HIV policy for six
months and there should be on the policy
this is V of tip number about the
reimbursements of the a in the past
three years the Perseus is around nine
thousand five hundred the second ian is
nineteen seven and five hundred patients
and in this year is a estimate along the
are forty three solid patients had been
treated and that are all well as we are
really not very hard
if the 97.5% we should order the air
available in Taiwan other if we just
reverse the treatment we if we just
increase the recommendation and a
certain rates of Adi balancers I see the
current situation
we just only can increase the the Latino
population from 10% to 20% it means that
we increase the convention and a second
rate from 70% to 100% because of all the
patient will receive a DLC and we we
have Arsenal around a hundred percent of
the page in which India will be killed
oh it just only can cure 20% of our
patient population in in a case we have
an Oda if we can increase a decent r1
and the increase the rate of
accessibility to 16% we also can cure
20% of our patient population without a
TA and you even can cure more on the
patient to 32% ipping can increase the
rate of diagnosis and also ability to
simplify problem so if we can in
combination with the increased rates of
diagnosis and accessibility to 75% and
introducing the new year road when we
can
respect to cumulative allocation in the
future therefore the Oscar to global
illumination is that it is panels and
the words words and theses are
circulating which in a feature
either it's very difficult to perform
the measurement imaging program at the
center because we empower you to the
budget impact so the alternative way to
achieve the finishing is to increment
micro elimination in certain population
or the circulation who is feasible but
he'll see the world to approach in a
shock convenient term is we have added
real targets a predictable timing cause
we can prevent a new or reinvention and
finally we can general temperance in
defined population to serve as a role
model for nation Peugeot this concept
also called Michael elimination so today
I want to show you two in general
Michael imaging evacuating serving time
one the first one is to reduce a project
or micro mentioning as she rehab Albania
countries in southern Taiwan and the
target population is so-called the g1
achievable in the mirror in our previous
study we wondered that you don't come
beer sheva various on h3 translate
around the 20% but baby lo this is
awareness only 27% and eventually only
around the 5% notation have been changed
we slept again to entrust all and then
review the gap in each care cascade all
the HCV treatment that we find there
choose the Cape in the technologies will
give India suitability and if you kept
in the accessibility
therefore we possibly are targeted to
village in the village 1 and B 2 with a
population along though for some in 500
and conducted a program to regional
gable each other each Shiva care cascade
we call it comprehensive micro emulation
our Civic patient in hyperendemic
village in Taiwan they can pick campaign
we apply a people central average risk a
system okay in this periscope we
organize the island how is your ice
cream team and put on the go by door
screen is she be happy
tell me earlier and then the
broadcasting bed to the dissenter
laboratory and find out the Achebe
accreditations and perform
ultrasonography as well as the fibers in
in the community under them before the
patient who are eligible for treatment
should actually treated and secondary
said that we sell an outreach actually
to the team locally it is considered
most North Asian technicians and
promised in the community
therefore the patient want to be
referred to the Medical Center far away
from the community to increase
accessibility but she be treatment so
this is now advocated the problem and
also the newspaper of the HTV outreach
screen team and China team
study in Marshall in this year so this
is the initial report as you can see
during the past 15 years we have swing
around the chef's salad I'm rested here
in King Graham and turn around 20 suits
three percent of the rest and had been
the post visual bars it means that
entire cv+ and the seven percent
allocation which we've already only 20
so important that this is dominance and
only glimmers and happiness earth to
achieve abductor and only 5% of the
kitchen have been treated in this hyper
endemic area and in this year enough in
our on January 2 3 we pump
our camp at tea and that screen around
the to solid rest and in the two
villages and found that the anti see
Prince a given all the high eight the
2930 explains and assume it biodegrades
even a high at a 70 percent but the
design welness really increased a little
bit from 27% to discreetly 9% and the
disease are separate increases from 11%
to protein 8% and the kill rates
increased from 5% to 20% because of the
newly implementation of national
reimbursement assistant or ninja has our
programs in Taiwan either even use the
program you can see they're still a very
high gun around the 75 percent of the
page you need to be treated
therefore we perform the referral link
of the patient to the Mosul care treated
team in the arm in in through 2019 and
so far they are 234 patient had been
linked to care team and - and in percent
agree and assess the care team and 75
percent on the page have been initiated
with of the area trailer children and
71% of the patient ability is therapy
and we probably can achieve the micro in
machine by the end of 2020 next year
the second even though is the
Michael imitation program for a special
population of end-stage renal disease
patient population who are under
maintenance ephemeral Diaries are you in
are you treated patient populations so
as a first priority because this patient
population at a higher risk of all-cause
mortality and the liver with immortality
with a are you grading with the virus
and also hey Madonna's procedure is had
high risk of severe extinction so the
second reason to treat this patient
population is to to implement concept of
treatment as prevention in the high-risk
group
and before the deal Iran it has been
only around one to two percent of the
patients have been cured by taking the
phazon plasma Barbie because various
high adversely buttons and many patient
are ineligible or contrary gate
indicated through the techie independent
password so
we decided to implement the second
program for micro imaging in this
patient population and in this
population is very easy to conduct a
comprehensive surveillance so the
concept of this patient population is um
this is the goal of micro information
effectively you can provide the outreach
on-site surveillance and treatment we
can postulate the thing to care of this
patient population and treatment get to
the patient at the same time to prevent
a further invasion to the other
individuals so we call this a model or
she'll be like elimination as a receipt
key we send to be our first team three
teams are 200 the prima donnas center
around the southern part of the Taiwan
so the patient that they can receive the
screening assessment so the treatment
and the palpable in the hematology work
we don't need to be stood the liver
clinic
so this is our example that we
collaborate when t2 hematite Center in
southern Taiwan and actually in 2010 we
had access a comprehensive screening in
this patient population at the time
around the 70% of hemorrhoids patients
or see the past people and I see and the
70% all these antisocial palpation very
perennial but only 1% of the SUV
variations
they've been so several tree that we
split in the pillow on in 2010 and early
in this year we performed the second
time of comprehensive screening around
the two thousand and three hundred
occasion the anti G's she be first rate
in decreased a little bit around 70
percent
so 14 the same and they actually are
really rich among the anti CCO
participations also decrease from 70
fighters name to 56 percent it is
because around the 21 percent on the
patient had been susceptible treating we
study a regiment reimbursed by the
government
ah however you can see this year a
higher purpose limitation need to be
treated in this patient population
around 80 percent
so we conduct the post has to run in the
hematite room in consummating University
we have a baseline screening
Cymbeline and the sign also some chrome
so labruffey and the design goes in and
beside follow are all the are vs chibi
screening a circle and treatment and
follow perform in hematology edges and
in the in this example of all of the 15
machine burn patients under the hammer
dollar Center I've been treated with
scorn available the energy Bala it must
be a gorilla or creepy place on the
ballot in no time at the same time and
she's much later we find that all were
location at Sheila's be a chair so what
we can see we can say that we kill all
the shipping in this hematite i center
and we achieve the goal of from Hadassah
to know she
Hema dialysis that means that in this
demo data expected a normal need to
separate the shinny patients from the
others
about in your countries how to influence
micro in relation to special population
because it's a pair to cover information
of about stream balance
first of all target population and the
major of the cable each cbk cascades and
sever strategy to minimize again and
most importantly collaborate with geo
and NGO and look for resource and ever
advocated to public the most important
step is just to do it and so far there
are many special population has been
successfully treated as a dental or
micro imaging such as animal feed
occasion the prison the person with the
draw many manifestations man and the
many other special population finally I
would like to in the dish the nation
program or achieve control in Taiwan in
2016 the talent government decide to the
nation Hep C program office to establish
in the strategy to implement the
strategy and to elevate 8 a strategy for
HD nation a so called edited nation
label so the first factor is to prevents
the newest silly patient
the most powerless provisional
leadership in Beijing is public
education program for example the paper
liberal foundation found a serious
education program in the hyper limit
area and we found that implemented the
education program could reduce the in
Spain and the prevalence of achieving
patients significantly killed in the
classical care weeks up to the past few
years
the second strategies strategies to
increase the rate of diagnosis and words
silikal we will now need to add wallack
to use the power by the government we
also have to integrate the the power
non-governmental over an issue that
integrates the program to market purpose
communion surveillance
and also the nation has always our
decide to provide a free chair for
forgiveness as I see Marcus for adults
in Taiwan this age money 45 years old
this very powerful on strategy to
encourage the so-called baby boom
generation to do civil monetary
screaming and measure enable and the
third stated reserve strategy to
increase the susceptibility so far the
government allowed the rest prayer care
provider to provide porno care service
with specialized professional in your
areas and also in the community to
increase the link to care with our
profession with a CD to deceive the
average and finally the energy is to
scare the children optic are increasing
the budget and by introducing
one-size-fits-all regiments with
hardship array because II and the high
safety profile
therefore we Taiwan expected that we can
achieve the goal of a sealing machine by
2025 with the four steps strategy in a
three dimension so ladies and gentlemen
about the next step of your country to
think about to the micron image again
targets patient population major locate
on each case cap and the should indicate
as early as possible and the caliber
whiskey or non geo look fold all the
resource from Cumberland the Lumpur part
palapa domination and also the industry
and it's very important to advocate to
the public and adjust to each
for your teaching
Thank You professor you for your
informative presentation
we will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen I'll answer as
many questions as we have time forum
okay let's get started
our first question is so thank you for
your presentation and impressive case
study on Taiwan successful micro
elimination project did this initiative
start from the hospital government NGO
or geo and how long did it take to get
this project started
and for the two cases of Michael in
Venetian it is funded by the NGO post
and after the second step on the Odyssey
scoring program and the algae screen
team we collaborate with the hard people
to organize our discreet a team to
provide the professional treatments and
finally we ask the government to join us
to allow us to treat our patients
locally with the nation health insurance
I think the first step usually come from
a non NGO idea in the man to persuade
the hospital and persuade the government
that the my going managing is a good
seeing into the writing that we have to
do
usually each problem from the initiation
from be a deal to establish the in
changing our needle under nine months
great thank you okay your next question
is from your list of possible target
populations in resource-limited settings
and limited funding budget which would
you recommend to have the most impact
for our first project and where should
we start
for the resource constraint a the most
important target this high priority is
the lectionary high endemic population
with high-risk occupation such as a
homogenizes as a person who engage from
such as Mia Piven also the men is
success today
second high priority target population
irritation these are the ones of
fibrosis but it is very difficult to
find in the special populations who are
not reading the connect level we suggest
that we conquer the prosperity
population at the high-risk invasion
collect killaby IE many successes meant
the prison and also the hemodialysis
patients
great thank you thank you professor you
and do you have any final comments for
our audience
yes up
and just to eat you can make it
well I'd like to thank you again for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Abbott molecular
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us and for
their questions any questions we did not
have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration elaborate to
lure you via email when this webinar is
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event until
next time bye bye
bye-bye